[Music]
it's almost unfair that he's the sub
turbo pulsar
in some ways has been performing the
best in what we've seen
i think they have a strong shot at
making a long run turbo
the first player with a chance to give
himself two world titles
he could do it he did it last season as
a substitute for his team
and now he's trying to do it as a
starter can he pull it off
[Applause]
they want it they want it so bad
you're waiting for this for a while
three times three times i'm going for
the three time now
it's showing true emotion to how much
this guy
has to win because it's all he has
northern gaming wants to try and put
this next one in this is so close
for them they have a control turbo the
whole team
doesn't matter does it himself true
players got one player on the backboard
for renault vitality
turbo's taking a lot of time into the
middle of the field and it's gonna be
turbo
who
and he's absolutely unstoppable next
goal
is the rlcs world championship
turbo pulse ripping up high gets the
flick down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
pierre turbopulsa sulfur was born in
oceperia
near stockholm in sweden on august 9
1998.
growing up he was introduced to video
games by his father at a young age
and often played against his brother
when i first started playing video games
i was very young i was playing a lot of
fifa and nhl on playstation then i
switched to pc
and then when roughly came out just got
hooked rocket league was
undoubtedly a sports game but while the
formula was simple enough there was
incredible depth to be found
and when the rocket league championship
series was announced he knew he
had to be a part of it especially
because school never really grabbed his
attention
yeah i i was so like tired and
bored of school like as soon as the
class ended
i got my phone and then i got home and i
instantly got my pc like
didn't do homework until my dad started
yelling at me to do homework and
like school was nothing for me i think
gaming has always been there for me so
but those early years were difficult
turbo played with kapow and my mxg
before getting the call from pashi and
sikki to play with market esports in
mid-2016.
in spite of qualifying for the rlcs
season 1 finals with that roster
turbo never quite felt like part of the
team but that didn't make their
elimination from the event hurt
any less and i remember taking a taxi
with him back to the
airport just to kind of help and show
him along the way and i remember the
conversation i had with him in that taxi
he was like
he was just pissed he was unsatisfied
with the performance and you could just
see like this drive in him
about like i am not done while names
like remco
cook sir and kenovi dominated the
conversation in competitive rocket
league
turbo pulsa was on the sidelines some
players had heard of him but
he was a long way from a major podium
eventually
turbo joined northern gaming but this
time around
he found himself sitting on the bench
but he didn't
find himself there for long with maestro
being unable to attend the rlcs season 3
finals
turbo pulsa was given a chance to start
finally he had the opportunity to prove
that he could hang with rocket league's
best after sweeping just a minute gaming
they ran into energy esports
the top seed from north america the best
opportunity kept turbo pulse to get the
pass he misses the touch
and jacob flanks it away devel trying to
push it out of the play redcoats all
up to him but jacob will fake him out
again
sweeping more than jamie will move on to
the upper bracket for the first time in
land history for nrg they
finally take down a european team
they've been struggling with that fact
now when losers it would be a steep
climb back to the top
but not only that turbo was trying to
figure out his place in the team as they
were fighting for their tournament lives
devo told us he didn't really feel like
he can do whatever he
wants to do and it's holding him back
being around first told them
do whatever you want and we'll be behind
you
the mid-tournament adjustments seemed to
bring results throughout the team's
losers bracket run
and turbo was a key part of that
northern gaming wants to try and put
this next one in this is so close for
them they have a control
turbo the whole team doesn't matter does
it himself and he's got the lead
turbo coming and showing he's not just
himself he's an amazing player
what a trouble from him taking everyone
from the nile out
but an even stronger market esports was
waiting in the grand finals
and it was time to see if turbo and
northern gaming were ready
northern gaming one of our dynasties
here there was so many question marks
around them coming into this land
would they be able to perform with the
sub turbo pulsa and they have done
exactly that come up behind fairy peak
back towards the goalkeeper needs to get
there he's not going to touch it
in the most inopportune of goals makes
it happen and northern gaming wins game
three great people
but the confusion looks like on defense
for maca right now
they're not only sure who's going to go
for the clears devo looks for the
pressure open
double tap this hit the oceana region
named that move after this player and
look at him perform here on the world
stage
reading fairy picks first but what is
that with the save off to the side
turbo folsom will take another one into
the net get divo be there he puts it
through the one-two pass again
strikes and northern gaming has the lead
shutting it down the final countdown of
the final game of the world series here
devo to try and put it through
cannot make contact renko just shut it
down will it touch
fairy pete carries it high one goal can
still tie the game but devo will let it
touch
and northern gaming has done it when
they could not for the last two seasons
the world champion here in los angeles
[Applause]
[Music]
in the end they did the unthinkable
northern gaming
won the world championship with a sub
but for turbo it was more than that it
was validation that he
was good enough that he was worth more
than the bench
that he could face off against the best
players in the world
and he could win from there turbo pulsa
joined forces with kdop
and violet panda to form gale force
esports
and it wasn't long before that roster
began making waves across the scene
all the while turbo added another
dimension to his game
spicing things up with a little trash
talk were you feeling
good and confident coming into this
matchup against g2 because g2 is riding
off of a high from that you know victory
over chiefs
yeah i feel really really good coming to
this game uh we've been
practicing really hard we've been doing
well in scrims and
g2 is nothing without j nebs and he
wasn't doing
really well right now
but heading into the season 4 world
championship while the team had plenty
of success
they hadn't won a major lan constantly
getting podium finishes but
failing to take the top prize and the
pressure
was on turbo the first player with a
chance
to give himself two world titles he
could do it he did it last season as a
substitute for his team
and now he's trying to do it as a
starter can he pull it off
up against method in the grand finals it
was closing time
and turbo was ready to make history
currently belonging to gale force
esports and
every single reward that that reaps now
two players caught by the side
metronomes can't get there
canard wins
[Applause]
have proven just how skilled they are no
matter how much they've wavered roughly
play
they brought it out here undefeated
and when he was picked as mvp turbo
chose to honor someone that had become
more than a teammate
they were also a friend turbo though
this is your second
championship man how do you feel yeah i
have no words sex
if almost i feel like it upstream to
have that mp
well you know what you could do whatever
it is you want to do with the mvp if you
want to give the kid out by all means go
ahead
uh look at that he's gonna he's gonna do
it he's gonna do it
hey you know what everyone is an mvp
you're all champions
this is incredible now two seasons ago
turbo had been unable to find a spot on
a top roster and was forced to roll the
dice as a substitute
he came into the season with a lot to
prove now
he was the first two-time world champion
after
back-to-back wins and the tournament mvp
and he was doing it as a player who
wasn't focused on flashy individual play
he was winning because he was doing
whatever his team needed to win
giving whatever he could to the victory
some people
might not i don't want to give credit to
someone else i guess like
because i yes i'd rather have uh i
really do a nice pass
to my teammate who scores than a nice
girl because
like it feels better to know that i did
something like
that someone else might not have done
kind of putting your ego aside
so the greater good of the team can get
the thing that matters most which is a
world championship
i think turbo embodies that the ability
to not be the flashy in your face
whatever it is and take a step back and
and do the grunt work
you know he's there to you know do all
the heavy lifting
without all the credit but because he's
done it so many times he's earned it in
his own way
guilford stuck together and before the
season five finals even signed with a
resurgent dignitas organization
it had been another strong season and
dignitas were seen as the favorites to
repeat
but a familiar opponent looked poised to
stop it
nrg it was a familiar sight for turbo as
energy bumped his team into the lower
bracket
north america will be represented in the
upper bracket finals
but the question now remains carpet
who's joining them
the reigning world champion the
defending
title has now been dropped to the lower
bracket but turbo
was determined to win he wanted the
three-peat
[Applause]
they want it they want it so bad
e-u-n-a grand finals it is turbo
you're waiting for this for a while
three times three times i i'm going for
the three time now
it's getting easy right and the grand
finals between the two teams is one of
the best in rocket league history
no matter where you are you can play
either side of the field
wants to go the whole way oh my
goodness there's a help out now garrett
drops it down to the rookie
garrett can get there in time no
can valentina get enough control before
they drop back the defense you thought
the dealing he's got the flip
i think
remember it is not over yet but turbo
bolster
almost put in yet another highlight real
goal
it has hit the floor nrg
are in the lower brackets finds by the
panzer tries to take it to the net
now infield pass fighter panzer unmarked
straight back to
[Applause]
they are just slamming it off and
following their own touches there is the
third
there's the brace for garrett g
game seven is on the way
after winning the first series and
resetting the bracket a goal from turbo
looked like it would end
game seven but energy weren't going down
without a fight and fans got to witness
something
incredible and it's almost there justin
keeps it alive
wasn't
[Applause]
game seven final series overtime
and who better to finish it than turbo
pulsa
turbo pulse riffing up high gets the
flick down
free time wow champion
2017 had been called the year of turbo
pulsa but as his team lifted the trophy
again
in june of 2018 it looked like the
three-time champions reign
might last for years as he set the
record for most
goals in a single lan event but the
three friends
that had made history were about to
encounter a challenge that would change
everything
in season 6 dignitas coasted to an
impressive 21-4
finish during the european regular
season and then won
top seed in europe's finals it appeared
the storyline was set
continued dominance for europe and yet
more hardware for turbo
at the rlcs season six world
championship
cloud nine na's third seed surprised
everyone by making the finals
they're keeping at least one maybe even
two players back
one double commit their chance for cloud
nine if gimmick can get a strong shot
going for the double knot can he hit it
bounces
it by the defense gimmick with the
highlight reel shot
turbo not there quick enough squishy
has a chance going for the double tap
himself bounces
squishy extends the lead
[Applause]
switchy passes to itself
[Applause]
the kings of rocket league and you can
see
turbo a class act there
cloud nine it
seemed impossible carpet turbo
was devastated it hadn't been all that
long since his days riding the bench but
he'd become accustomed to winning
despite his supportive style and his
selfless approach to the game
he was a true competitor and second
place just
wasn't good enough something that people
didn't see is after they lost in season
six backstage
he's sobbing he's crying on someone's
shoulder because he cares
that much it's the sign of a true
competitor the guy
cares so much he lives and breathes this
game if turbo
kdop and violent panda had to find an
era in rocket league
then kdop's departure after the season
six finals was the
end of that era his replacement yukio
played well at dreamhack
leipzig where dignitas beat kdop's new
team for no vitality
we still await a winner
terrible shoots
but the rlcs regular season was a
different story
kdob went on a absolute tear earning the
mvp for the region's finals as they took
first place the man who'd been turbo's
teammate
his friend the man he'd given his mvp
medal to
on stage had become turbo's greatest
obstacle
dignitas they need to score with time
left violet panza
one more pass yukio another to turbo
it's not gonna happen time expires psg
steady the course right the ship they're
headed to new jersey
and they take out dignitas to do it
no one could have imagined a world where
dignitas
is not representing the european region
at the world championship
there was something going on i think
with that team where they just
no longer were gonna stay together and
you saw kdop leave and that didn't help
and then all of a sudden turbo's now
leaving
so the perception i think for the
community was yeah this guy's not gonna
do much
and then for him to completely change
that like that was the start
of it all he goes from winning that to
dreamhack in 2017 in sweden where he
plays with gale force roster as a tryout
and then they just win and then they win
again
and then they win again it was wild
turbo had always seized opportunities
when they presented themselves
and after a devastating loss after
missing out on the world championship
altogether
he knew he needed to make a change turbo
wanted to beat kdop
he wanted to prove that the best team in
the world was still whichever one he was
on
and so when turbo was at his lowest
point in years
he took another one and he made history
again
becoming the first european player to
join a top n a team
nrg with fire burner out of the lineup
and the talented duo of garrett g and
justin looking for a third
turbo saw another chance for glory and
then
the new pickup turbo pulsa coming all
the way from sweden the three times
world champion
and your overtime hero these guys are
out for blood
and once again his characteristic
support play was exactly what his team
needed
they tore through na on route to another
dominant regional finals win
turbo's first outside of europe but now
facing down the rest of the world he had
an opportunity to become the first
four-time world champion in rocket
league history
and once again vitality and kdop stood
in the way in the grand finals
these guys easily top six in the world
it's gonna be
a battle and i said yesterday that this
matchup was a rocket league classic i
wasn't
kidding and we get it again up again
he's unrelenting at this moment and he's
absolutely unstoppable
turbo on the hunt for yet another hat
trick
already too we're not even halfway
through this game
player on the backboard for renault
vitality turbo's taking a lot of time
into the middle of the field and it's
gonna be turbo
turbo answers the call and justin
doesn't want to see any of it
justin who has he got left
[Applause]
johnston with the biggest
demo of his life
and at the end of an incredible back and
forth series
it all came down to one incredible
overtime
shot to this corner very pink he's got
past two players
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
has felt like a long time coming but for
this team it felt even longer
you're winners
turbo was the four-time world champion
winning literally half of all the season
finals
up to that point he was the tournament
mvp
and he brought energy and north america
a world
championship he'd gone from riding the
bench to ruling
the world he'd done it on different
teams in different regions
and he'd overcome every giant that stood
in his way
and he didn't do it with insane shots he
did it by grinding up from the very
bottom
doing whatever it took and by making
every team that he joined
better
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages